how's it going bros my name is Pierre
2pac you've read the title it's time to
vote
it's been way too long since we did a
series Bros and I I really missed it you
know so I selected a few games that I'm
really interested in and you can go
ahead right now and vote you should be
able to see a screen right now with all
the selections I'll leave some info on
each game in the description and if you
are on a tablet you can vote by clicking
the links in the description otherwise
you vote by clicking on the game that
you think is the most interesting one
click means one vote so click away and
everything will be okay you have 24
hours to vote it's gonna be interesting
I'm curious to see which one you bros
are more into the reason why I want you
bros to vote is because I don't want to
just play games myself I want to play
games with you bros and that i it might
seem like a small detail but it's
important to me and it makes it so much
more fun if you bros are digging it as
well otherwise I can just play games
myself right so yeah I really appreciate
your brothers input on this and thank
you so much for showing your support I
will see you in the next series go ahead
and vote in the meanwhile there is a
brofist for yet stay awesome bros broke